[Music]
i'm well pal i'm well
i used to have a my chief secret service
agent every time we go by
greenwall we had to bless ourselves
inside and be silent about
it's a reverent undertaking though you
boss
appreciate that i remember i
met with the freak when i was vice
president they had me go down to spring
training
and i uh and i was it turned out it was
the yankees
and uh my head secret service agent who
now
runs nbc's security wore
red sox socks and he pulled up his his
uh his pants a little bit so everybody
could see him
and when a rod gave me a bat he wouldn't
he told me he said he's not gonna let me
put it in the car
oh and i don't know hey mike how are you
good to see you
spencer janet how are things up in maine
great mr president sorry am i muted
you're unmuted now
hi tim how are you i know minnesota is
great but it can't be as nice the
weather is originally in mexico now is
there
sure anyway you all are nice to
take away summer yeah
well they're i'm just waiting for them
to tell me when we get going here since
we're live streaming this
you're good oh ready to go okay
well first of all hi everybody it's good
i'm supposed to look over here and out
of you guys
but we got six governors with us today
democrats and republicans here
and i'm reading the moment governor
mills of maine governor dewine of ohio
governor cox of udall governor
walls of minnesota governor baker
massachusetts and governor lujan grisham
of
mexico and it's great to connect with
you all
you know last week i provided an update
on
where we were with our vaccination
program and
and what comes next and i said our goal
uh by july the 4th is to have 70 percent
of adult americans with at least
one shot and 160 million americans fully
vaccinated
and that's a pretty huge goal i
acknowledge that but you've done a
remarkable job but if we
succeed we're going to be able to take a
serious step toward
return to normalcy by by independence
day which is a goal that was
not arbitrarily but based on talking of
the docs thought if we did what we had
to do we could meet
and there's a lot of work to do though
to get there but i believe we can get
there
part of the reason i'm so confident is
because of
your leadership the governors and uh and
your partnership
with us the governors with us today and
their
counterparts have been instrumental in
helping us make progress and
more quickly than anyone would have
thought working together
we delivered over 220 million shots in
my first hundred days well beyond
anyone's expectations
but because of their cooperation and
today more than 150 million americans
have gotten at least
one shot over 115 million americans are
fully vaccinated
nearly 85 percent of people excuse me
uh 65 and over have gotten at least one
shot
and whether it's a red state or a blue
state black white latino
aapi americans from every walk of life
are getting their vaccines we got more
to do though
now cases and hospitalizations and
deaths are all
down tens of thousands of moms and dads
brothers and sisters
grandparents neighbors friends are still
with us who
i believe whom would have otherwise we
would have lost but for the work of
these governors
and millions of americans are starting
to live life more normally after more
than a year of sacrifice
and i know everybody's tired hearing me
say this online here but it isn't
democratic progress or republican
progress
it's american progress and now now we've
got to take the next step together
i know uh every week you meet with
jeff science who's here with me and he
you go through it and
i've had a chance to meet with the
governor's conference and others but
it's we we decided from the very
beginning as you all remember
uh that how many gov did you speak with
in the last
just today well today we had our weekly
call so i hope
most governors attend that call which is
great and uh but the point is
that we know we want to get something
done it's all about
governors and mayors and county
executives all local it's on the street
and to meet the goal that i set last
week we need to accomplish three things
in my view
one we have to make it easier and more
convenient for all americans to get
vaccinated you're busting your neck
doing that
two to build confidence in vaccines by
delivering facts
and answer questions to anyone who might
have one and have thorough answers
and three by ensuring that we reach
everyone
with an equitable response that as
as a as we enter this next phase and
help us get there
we've added two new tools one
uh americans can go to vaccines.gov
or they can text their zip code
to three excuse me bespoke
their zip code text it to four
three eight eight two nine let me say it
again
four three eight eight two nine
and they'll get at least three locations
near them
with vaccines in stock at that moment
and in my direction more than twenty
thousand pharmacies coast to coast are
now offering
walk-in vaccinations by no appointment
necessary
and the governors or you all are
stepping up to increase the availability
of walk-in vaccinations as well
the federal emergency management agency
fema
is shifting focus from larger
vaccination sites to smaller
community-based sites
and mobile clinics to reach more people
where they are
and we've recently made significant new
investments around
vaccine education including funds to
help states and community organizations
get the word out on the local level
just yesterday the food and drug
administration expanded the emergency
youth officer
authorization for the pfizer vaccine for
children
12 to 15 years of age 12 to 15.
that more parents that means parents who
who want to protect their children
younger teens want to get vaccinated
we're a step closer to that goal now
and today i'm also announcing an
additional steps
to ensure that transportation is less of
a barrier
from may 24th through july 4th
uber and lyft uber and lyft are both
going to offer
everyone free rides to and from
vaccination sites
i think that is really stepping up both
uber and lyft
free rides two they'll wait and from
they'll take you back home and it makes
it easy for
students who will work with federal
pharmacy partners
to bring on campus vaccine sites to
dozens of the nation's largest community
colleges this summer
and i want to thank the governors here
for making it easy as possible for
students to get vaccinated
and finally i'm announcing today that
fema is making support available
immediately for community vaccination
outreach efforts
this will help states tribes territories
local governments
and community and faith-based
organizations to make more progress on
the ground
things like phone banking door-to-door
canvassing
pop-up vaccination sites and workplaces
and houses of worship
and so once again governors
in so many states particularly the six
that are here
have been essential partners in this
effort and they know it isn't about
politics it's about saving lives and
livelihoods
rebuilding our economy and getting us
back to our way of life
so it gets to have uh so you know the
idea that we have six of the best
governors who worked on this
with me today is really a pleasure and
uh
all of you have done a remarkable job
and with your permission i'd like to
hear
from you about the best practices and
innovations that have
worked for you what you've learned
across these three areas and improving
access
building confidence and ensuring equity
i'd like to start by talking about
improving access to vaccines
governor mills maine and governor dewine
of ohio
both of you have developed creative
programs to meet people where they
are governor mills if you don't mind i'd
like to ask you how
how are you reaching out to people and
encourage them to get vaccinated and
what kind of success you have
thank you mr president and thank you for
all you're doing to help us get shots in
arms
um it's a great honor to join you and
fellow governors
across the nation to share these
innovative ways that maine is
vaccinating people against coba 19.
maine has had some of the lowest numbers
of cobin 19 cases
hospitalizations and deaths in the
country since the uh on
onset of the pandemic but the people of
our state believe in the science
and they have followed public health
protocols to prevent the spread of the
virus
now we are closing in on the 70 percent
of adults that you want us to close in
on
seventy percent of adults in maine
having received at least one dose of
coca-19
vaccine the goal you set right now we're
at 67 percent
all right and about and about 53
of all eligible people in maine are
fully vaccinated
well that achievement has not been
without challenges
we're a rural state as you know of 1.3
million people the most dispersed
population of any state in the lower 48
with small cities with towns surrounded
by blueberry barrens potato fields and
forests
towns on islands people living at the
very end of a road
in fact when we asked people in maine to
stay six feet apart
or as the fishermen say one fathom some
people
asked why so close
we're also the oldest oldest state in
the nation
more than 20 percent of our population
being over 65 so
low population density and age are our
big challenges
when we began this massive logistical
undertaking
getting vaccines into shut into arms we
focused on
equity we focused on addressing what
made us the most
most vulnerable to the virus so we knew
that older individuals were more likely
to get very sick and suffer and die
so after healthcare providers and first
responders
we then began vaccinating people over 60
over the age of 60. as the supply
increased thank you very much
and as we expanded we expanded
eligibility by age
by april 7th everyone 16 and older was
eligible
today as i mentioned more than half of
all eligible people are
fully vaccinated nearly every day
our state has led the nation in getting
shots in arms
but we're not dropping our guard we're
not slowing down
every shot in arm we know is a death
prevented
a life saved a family kept whole
so maine is doubling down on access
especially in hard to reach communities
and for people who are hesitant
like the woman in western maine who
drove a truck five miles down from her
mountaintop home would be the first
line at the pharmacy one morning if you
build it we thought
they will come
with remarkable cooperation by our big
health care systems
we started with the mass fascination
clinics for the national guard
local personnel and volunteers now we
are participating with fema on a mobile
vaccination unit
that's getting to those hard to reach
people and underserved populations
we have drive through clinics for adults
with intellectual and developmental
disabilities we're hosting pop-up
clinics for hard-to-reach groups
at their workplaces we've vaccinated
homebound seniors
in their homes and we've expanded
walk-in hours in morning and
late evening hours for shift workers
like the woman working the night shift
in a bakery in lewiston
we brought clinics to the islands for
fisherman's families
we've operated clinics at houses of
worship from mosques to the methodists
and like many other states we've offered
free transportation and a very smooth
vaccination experience
but i'm pleased to announce to you that
as of today
for those who get their first shot
between now and memorial day
we're offering a voucher from our fish
and wildlife department and our
parks and conservation folks and from
retailers like l.l bean
the portland sea dogs our miner league
baseball team charlie knows so well
and the oxford plane speedway our
biggest racetrack to get free tickets to
a ball game or a race event
a free fishing license or hunting
license or gift card for outdoor gear
we're calling this your shot to get
outdoors
oh it's corny i know but we know that
people in maine have found refuge and
religion mother nature
throughout the pandemic so these
incentives will encourage that outdoor
activity while getting more shots in
arms
as quickly as possible so thank you mr
president for your support
for all the states maine is doing
everything we can to put this pandemic
behind us
we're giving it our best shot thank you
well go thank you thank you i um
i think that it's remarkable what you're
doing
and uh you know i uh excuse me
uh i um well i'll i'll get back i want
to hear from mike first then i want to
ask you
both a question by may mike gov
fire away ohio mr president thank you
for doing this we appreciate you
listening
uh i want to say hi to jeff and tell
him we appreciate his work and the fact
that he listens and
we're on the phone again today so that's
very very helpful to us
mr president we've taken a community
approach to this
ohio is a state of communities
uh we started off right from the word go
about 650 locations
we're now up to 1900 okay locations
uh where people can get the shot in
addition to that we have
new pop-up places every day we have
the mobile clinics out as well
that's work that's worked exceedingly
exceedingly
well we started early on uh
with pharmacies and um that's we think
that that has been very
important as well as our health
departments as well as our federally
qualified
clinics uh our hospitals
we have um a lot of nursing homes
and a lot of assisted living in ohio i
think over 1700
and of course we have a lot of deaths
and though the first thing that we did
on day one literally
was to start focusing on those nursing
homes and assisted living
once we made the working with the
federal government
three passes through these nursing homes
we knew that that was not enough though
because we knew that they would be
taking in new people
they would have new residents every day
they would have new employees every day
so we have set up a
vaccine maintenance program that's
working with their pharmacy
and is making sure that every single
week they've got new vaccine going in
to these 1700 nursing homes and i think
that that makes a huge difference again
taking it to to people where they are
our national guard is going out and has
been going out for weeks
into uh senior housing taking it right
into the lobby
setting up shop vaccinating people all
they have to do is come down from their
rooms
and that has worked we think uh very
very well we're really decentralized in
ohio mr president we have 113 local
health departments
and it's the local health departments
it's the mayors it's the counties
they are the ones who are really the the
action is so i'm on the phone every
monday morning
for 45 minutes with every one of our
health departments
and i learn a lot they tell us what what
they need
what we can do to help them we try to
get them right away whatever whatever
they need
but we also hear from them the
innovation that they're doing
innovation as you know as you said at
the beginning comes locally
and so we'll take that innovation from
one health department what they're doing
and then
make sure that other health departments
are aware of that and other other
providers around the state
are aware of that so it's very very very
important
um we have taken a vaccine in august
excuse me in february we went out and
vaccinated every teacher in the state
who wanted to be vaccinated we actually
took
the vaccine to a place close to them in
some cases it was
directly into their school that enabled
us to open up
virtually every single school on on
march 1st
and again it was taking it to them uh
we've done the same thing with colleges
uh before college was out for the summer
uh we've done it with working with our
labor unions and we've done it working
with
businesses a lot of innovation going on
in businesses what we've found is the
businesses
that have us come in have a
have a health partner that does it they
work very closely with their employees
and they're able to get an uptake that
quite candidly i don't think we would
have gotten any other way
but by taking that directly directly
into that
into that business we are really at the
ground game now we've always been at the
ground game
uh but i think you're seeing governors
you know
continue to push out and go to where
people
people are we have some health
departments are literally out knocking
on knocking on doors we have
mobile clinics going around and we want
to reach people
you know exactly where they are just a
couple of observations
there certainly has been a appetite
for the johnson and johnson uh we're
seeing that
people who really want johnson john's
they want that one shot
and to be done there also clearly was an
appetite for walk-up clinics
uh and so most of the clinics in ohio
as you said are open for walk-ups and
people there's
people who just want to go they want to
make up their mind that day and go out
and be able to knock on the door finally
we're
very very excited about being able to
vaccinate
12 13 14 and 15 year olds and we've got
plans
in school we also have plans in the
summer
uh with boys club girls clubs feeding
programs and other things trying to take
this to
where people are so thank you for doing
this mr president
well thank you both for what you guys
are doing and one of the things that
i wanted to ask governor mills is that
uh
the idea of engaging in
and offering benefits like everything
from
fishing licenses on my guess is
free tickets and vouchers my guess is
that's probably going to work
i mean do you have any i think so we're
offering a great
spectrum of things and i think it'll be
an incentive to those who are still
maybe still hesitant you know uh people
would love to go to
l.l bean or go online and buy uh
buy a new hunting vest or whatnot and
people who want to go to the sea dogs
because as charlie baker knows the
season has opened up
i think it's a good incentive i know
other states are doing something
different
some are offering shots of booze but
can i ask you uh both of you one one
last question i'm sorry to
take so long here but i'm interested
tell me about what
the mobile vaccine
unit is like i mean are you driving
around in a uh
with docks in a pickup truck or yeah i
mean
no i mean deadly earnest for people this
is
being zoomed that uh talk to me about
if you each tell me what you're doing i
i've been through our mobile unit
and um it's very attractive very clean
it's a
trailer kind of thing
a vehicle and it's staffed by people
from the united states health service
public health service
and some national guard and some fema
people it's a great
uh level of cooperation among those
agencies and with the state of maine and
local governments
and i've seen people delighted being
able to drive up get out
walk through the trailer sit sit back in
their car for 15 minutes
be watched you know remotely and drive
off feeling free and clear
of comfort mike how about you
mr president uh all mobile clinics are
not alike at least in ohio
uh just a couple examples ohio ohio
northern university is going out
into small communities and they
announced when they're going to be there
they're going to be here
this afternoon in this community so it
allows people in smaller communities
to have it in their community and they
know when it's coming
we're seeing it in in cities uh since
cincinnati this
past a few days ago and what they're
doing
is they're using that as a base but
they're going out
uh the one i saw was actually in a
library
but they use that mobile clinic as kind
of the base to
store um and to bring the the vaccine
out so it's going out it's
trying to be innovative trying to figure
out you know how do we take it directly
to people
the the reality is and my wife fran and
i
uh have been to i think 37 38 different
vaccine clinics
and we always talk to the people who are
getting vaccinated and
we talk to those who have who have maybe
hesitated in the past
and what you find is that sometimes
they've just been they've been waiting
um and they've been really waiting for
an
opportunity something that makes it
easier to do
it's not that they're against getting
vaccine they just haven't got around to
it yet and so
getting that person uh getting them
the vaccines make it easy make it
convenient
i think is very important well thank you
both you're doing a heck of a job i'd
like to turn to
governor cox now of utah and governor
walls of minnesota another critical
issue is increasing confidence
among people who are hesitant to get the
vaccine
governor cox i know you're bringing
community leaders in to build confidence
tell me about your efforts
and and what how how it practically is
function what you're seeing
from those efforts well thank you mr
president it's great to be with you we
we
appreciate jeff uh taking all of our
complaints
over the the past few months he he's
been uh he's been remarkable in helping
us
resolve all of those and mostly by the
way he doesn't know any pharmacies i
just want you guys to know
we're very well aware but hey thanks for
allowing us to participate and highlight
some of the uh some of the good things
i'm doing and uh that are working well
uh by the way just an aside to a tip for
our media partners i occasionally see
reporting
that focuses on what percentage of the
total population has been vaccinated
uh that's great for places like maine
with the oldest population in the
country
for places like utah with the youngest
population in the country and of course
a large significant portion of our our
state that is not eligible to be
vaccinated
uh that's that's not exactly the right
uh metric to be using but we're very
excited for the announcement to allow
younger people to get vaccinated because
utah has more of them
than anywhere else mr president we're
really good at having kids here so
we're we're excited to uh to have that
that opportunity
when you talk about hesitancy though um
i i want to mention
that it's most important to uh to be
very flexible and adaptable what was
working a month ago
isn't necessarily going to work today of
course we have a vision for where we
want to go
and uh where we are in this phase of the
vaccination campaign
data collection is absolutely critical
and this is something
i want to mention that the governor
dewine just just touched on but
what we while some states go into the
field to do some polling
we are in the field every day of every
week constantly getting
new data to understand that population
that is remaining
that hasn't gotten the vaccine and i
think that's that's really important for
everyone
to uh to understand there we often just
talk about the vaccine hesitance a
hesitant population is one big group but
it's really it's really much more than
that
um i like to say we've moved from what i
call the vaccine ecstatic
and the vaccine excited phase and we're
now in the the vaccine
busy or the the vaccine period phase
um these aren't people that that refuse
to get it they're just
they just haven't gotten around to it
yet and i think we have to approach
all of these groups a little differently
but with that data that's allowed us to
really focus on three specific areas the
the why the who and the where um
to overcome this vaccine presidency we
designed a public information campaign
that not only answers questions and
resolves concerns
but it helps people understand that
getting the vaccine is the way to get
back to the things that we we all love
that we all want to do
um you know weddings and family reunions
uh utah jazz games uh the the best
people in the league right now
uh churches hugging grandparents
quinceaneras all of those things that we
care about
we want people to understand that the
vaccine is really the key to ending that
and that's one area where we could use
some help from uh from the white house
and
others and that is modeling what a fully
vaccinated person can
do i i like to say that we have fully
vaccinated people we should start acting
like it
and that's a big motivation to get the
unvaccinated to what to
want to uh to get back to me next up
we focus on the who and i think mr
president this this may be the most
important of all
through our research it became clear
that people trust their family doctors
their local community leaders and church
leaders their family
friends and neighbors a lot more than
they trust government on this issue
so we've been working directly with
those different voices to empower them
and give them a platform to encourage
vaccinations
which which leads to the third and and
the other governors have talked about
this so i won't take as much time
but the where is so important for this
next
phase and the next group of people now
that we have enough vaccine for it for
everyone
and so we these mobile pop-up clinics
that we're talking about
really matter and when you partner with
those the who
the right voices in a community so for
example in our latino community
we're working with churches and pastors
who will bring these mobile
pop-up clinics right to the church where
people can go and get those vaccinations
we've opened a portal to any
organization in our state
businesses churches nonprofits
uh summer camps anyone that wants a
mobile vaccination clinic
can request one we go directly to them
they have a party people can come and
get vaccinated
and we're finding that those trusted
voices are helping us
with that next phase of people who are
who are a little unsure or just didn't
have enough time to get around to it
we're taking out all of the excuses and
not get it back
and that that's where we are now mr
president we're excited as we continue
to reach towards that goal of getting 70
of our adults vaccinated well you're
doing a heck of a job uh
and the idea you're talking about is
what we nationally can do in terms of
making drawing a portrait of what it
means if you're fully vaccinated what
you can do and what you can't do
relative to the rest of the population
and we're just getting there now to the
degree that i think you're going to see
a more aggressive
effort on our part to lay out that
once vaccinated it's not only you can
hug your grandchildren you can do a lot
more
and whether or not you have to have even
at some point soon
mask inside versus outside i mean
so we're and if anything we've been
we've gone a little slower to make sure
we're exactly right
as terms of the percent of the
population that has
been vaccinated the the adult population
but
i think jeff we're going to be moving on
that the next
little bit yeah i think we expect more
and more guidance from the cdc
for vaccinated people and you know it's
uh
it's not everything but it's uh i i
think you're right about
it would increase the prospects of the
desire to get vaccinated
um you know as well
and uh one of the things uh
tim what uh are you seeing up in
your state right now well first of all
thank you mr president for uh for making
this opportunity uh available i'll echo
our thanks to jeff science and his team
they they pick up the phone no matter
what the question is and they get us
answers
i'd like to give a special thank you to
the other governors who are on here
they have been a source of information
and inspiration best practices as we
share together and uh
i would certainly associate myself with
governor cox's remarks when it comes to
confidence and how to get it done
i do think making that connection of
what it means to get vaccinated and get
it done
quickly we saw here in minnesota where
along with michigan we saw
a spike here recently in this latest
surgery on the b117 variant
but because of the availability of the
vaccine the speed that it had gotten out
we were able to blunt that and what that
meant was is hospitals did not become
overwhelmed
we did not have to close back down doing
many of the things we were doing
and the most important thing is far
fewer people died from that so
this idea of getting it into arms and
getting it out there has real world
consequences and and i i do agree
the competence is is based on the data
governor cox is exactly right we believe
in the data we believe in transparency
and for the governors who are on here
this is kind of the bane of our
existence um of trying to get this data
because it gets pouched on
you're not doing this you're doing that
but i think being
transparent open and use that data with
the public shows them you measure
what you care about and and that's how
we focus uh much like it sounds like
utah and my guess is many others are
doing it
but each state's a little different and
i think we had some built-in advantages
one is we had trusted third-party
validators like the mayo clinic
to be able to validate some of this data
but we also have a tradition here
we uh we have the highest voter turnout
in the last election
we also have the highest census return
i'm sure that's to the angst of new york
but we were able to do that and the
strategies that it takes to get people
to vote like governor cox said some are
very enthusiastic about it
some maybe go if they have the
opportunity same thing with the census
so what we understood was is the folks
who make those so successful
are local trusted partners as you've
heard and one of the great success
stories is
is listening to those folks who know how
to do it here in minnesota we have 11
sovereign tribal nations they did this
better than anybody else in the country
they focused on their elders
they focused on multi-generational
households and they focused on
delivering where people were at
uh that same model were kind of one of
the centers of
of pork and poultry production
those facilities were some of the
hardest hit they are many of them
are communities of color and immigrant
community there are multi-generational
households that can spread amongst a
nexus of iowa south dakota minnesota
and those communities had many reasons
to be hesitant they were hit hard there
were casualties
there was a lack of trust in those
communities so there's a story got told
on pbs newshour
a young organizer named jessica velasco
used some of those principles in her
community where she was well known
knocked door to door and we saw some of
the highest rates of uptake on the first
days
above 70 in these facilities where we
were doing multi-generational
vaccinations so it again it's not
assuming these people are hesitant
they're ideologically opposed
it's trying to understand where they're
at what are the differences
some are going to respond differently to
different groups
and then just candid these these
outreach the buses
um the pulling into parking lots uh
tonight i i see governor baker's there
i'll be
at the the saint paul saints opener a
twins affiliate and we're giving
vaccinations to folks coming through the
gate
as they come there they know that a
vaccinated uh saints fan
is someone in the seats and it's
starting to connect all these with
partners
and when i got my vaccine i i was glad i
took my friend along a a predecessor of
mine
former uh republican governor tim
paulini and we got vaccinated together
and
and my message to folks there is there's
a lot of good reasons to get vaccinated
but for some of them
you know if you need another one go get
vaccinated so you're alive to vote
against me in the next election i don't
care
i just want to get it done and i think
this idea of not
shaming people not thinking that it
wasn't there understanding that maybe
you have a
an expecting mother who wants more
information data
third-party validators and then trusted
delivery methods of this and and we used
the
the voting census model on a way to get
that out there
and then partnered and and brought it to
where people are at and and i'm proud to
say we're at 64
of your goal today mr president we will
be there um but i think all of us know
this is going to be a little longer
process but folks are coming along
so i want to thank you for uh for
highlighting this and i want to thank
the fellow governors for all the advice
and
and good ideas they've been able to give
to us well tim you've been a stand-up
guy
and going out and and uh just
reaching out to every every place you
can and one of the things that i've
found
and i've been to an awful lot of
vaccination sites around the country
and in my home state is that
it really does get down to for that
person who allegedly is
an anti-vaxxer he gets down in many
cases just to convenience
like you're walking through the gate oh
yeah okay i'm here go ahead
you know give me a shot i can do it um
and uh that's what
i i've been so impressed and it doesn't
surprise me actually
that governors and local officials are
really good at knowing
how to do that it's a little bit like
you know getting out the census as you
said
so i appreciate that now i uh
you know uh before we hear from the
final two governors i
i want to bring uh my top advisor on
health equity and uh
uh governor marcelo nunez smith and uh
governor i made her a governor doctor i
i just i'm not sure whether you view
that as a promotion or a demotion but
i i think it's a promotion uh but anyway
uh
uh tell us what's going on and give us a
quick overview of
the work you've been doing to do to
ensure
the equity response because we've been
told that you know that
in fact anyway i'll let you do the
talking here
thank you so much good afternoon mr
president good afternoon
governor is just so very good to be with
you today
uh i wanna echo and thank you so much to
you all your teams
all that you're doing to center equity
in your vaccination
campaigns uh as you've even referenced
it's important for us to hold a very
broad
understanding of the many groups that
have been hard hit by the pandemic
just for the minutes today though i want
to focus in on
race and place on people of color and
virality
in particular and i want to share some
of what
we're finding in the federal vaccination
channels
you know from the very beginning in
those channels it was
key as you all have done to take a very
intentional approach to center on equity
in the general program that meant taking
a place based approach
we recognize in our country zip code
is still a stronger predictor of health
and genetic code and so we
anchor in the location and place to make
sure that we're getting those resources
to the hardest hit and highest rates
communities
so setting up direct allocation to our
country's community health centers
and including to rural health clinics to
local independent chain pharmacies
and of course to the community
vaccination centers
and as so many of you are referenced
already supporting mobile capacity
that is key to meeting people exactly
where they are
so i want to share with you some of the
demographic data we have high quality
demographic data
and lift up and echo the need for data
to drive our response
and so in the federal vaccination
channels what we see
is encouraging about 70 of vaccinations
at community health centers have been
administered to people of color
and that number is 60 for the community
vaccination centers
and those are all all of them located in
hard-hit communities
now over 40 percent of the pharmacies in
the federal retail pharmacy program are
located in high risk areas
and if we look in the last two weeks
over 46 percent of those pharmacy doses
have been administered to people of
color
so of course there is absolutely more
work to do
as you all illustrate equity work
reaching to communities that's
hyper local so key
to recognize that communities are the
experts in what they need
and to partner as the examples have
really
showed partnering with trusted local
community leaders
is a must so we're all looking forward
together as the vaccination efforts
charge on prioritizing access focusing
in on ease
and convenience and addressing those
structural barriers you begin to talk
about
making sure people have the opportunity
to get connected to vaccine without an
appointment
making sure that there is paid time off
for vaccination and any recovery time
and thinking about other things like
transportation and providing that
assistance so in addition to making sure
that everyone has
access to vaccination we have to make
sure they have access to the
accurate information about vaccines from
the people that they know
from the people that they trust so
making sure that
everyone that is every person every
community
can benefit from this scientific
discovery
you could all agree that's how we all
together get to the other side of the
pandemic
so just as i wrap i want to say we know
equity does not
happen by default and it never has so
thank you
for all you're doing for sustaining this
commitment and of course
for your leadership well thank you very
much
and now i want to bring in governor
baker massachusetts and governor
lujan grisham in mexico who've been
focused on equity in their states
responsible
to respond to this pandemic and
first to you gov governor baker
uh can you share with us how the
commonwealth is making sure that every
community has access
and and information and opportunity to
get vaccinated and tell me
if you don't mind give me give me your
opinion whether you think
uh lyft and uh and you know these two
outfits are gonna provide free
transportation it seems to me
where i come from a lot of the uh
communities of color use these uh
facilities
uh and uh because they don't have
automobiles uh
so anyway i don't want to hold you up in
the game here either charlie but
you you've been doing a hell of a job
across the board you really have
i hope that doesn't ruin your reputation
coming from a democrat
but you're doing a hell of a job thank
you very much thank you very much mr
president and i'm going to
also give jeff zeitz and his team a
shout out for
all the work they've been doing to help
us help you the american people succeed
in getting vaccinated
massachusetts is uh number two in the
country we have about 74
of our adult population that's gotten a
first dose
my friends north of us in vermont are
ahead of us and we're going to do all we
can to catch up to them
um but our program was basically what i
referred to as a mixed model
our mass vaccination sites did about a
million shots but we also had regional
collaboratives
with local boards of health and local
providers in areas where
we had a lot of geography between and
among people
we had tremendous participation from our
healthcare community all the way from
the
hospital systems to the physician
offices and our community health centers
were a big part of the show for us
very early on and and with respect to
equity one of the places we started
straight out of the gate
was a big aggressive program to do
outreach to
congregate care and this meant you know
group homes that take care of people
with developmental disabilities and
mental health issues it meant
hitting a lot of the senior sites that
weren't part of the pharmacy program it
also met
um it also meant going after uh homeless
shelters and some of the folks who
worked and
were residents there and and i think in
many ways
um that approach which you know sort of
targeted a variety of different
uh objectives early on is is the way we
framed it all the way through and our
community health centers
um to sort of follow up on on several
previous comments have been big players
for us
and uh and in some cases they've been
partnering with
um with hospitals and with churches
and senior centers and community centers
and mobile
uh vaccine players to do pop-up clinics
and it's very interesting when you have
a when you have the muscle of a big
hospital system that can be a big
supporter of a community health center
that's running a program
in conjunction with them in a church or
a community center or a senior center
you basically got all the trusted voices
in that particular neighborhood
working together delivering the same
message which is that this is a good
idea and this is something that you
should be willing to do
and we of course track our data as well
and we've managed to successfully
vaccinate
uh so far our hispanic community our
asian community our black community a
race that's right up there with
our our white community as well we still
have some work to do there but we've
made a lot of progress
and and i guess i would say that i think
the transportation issue is a big deal
and and the decision to include folks
like lyft and uber and this can make a
big difference
we have special programs for homebound
folks that we do in conjunction with our
local boards of health where they are
literally identifying populations
that can't get to a vaccination site no
matter how close it might be
and making sure that we're going out and
then meeting them where they are and
making sure they get vaccinated
the same way everybody else does i i
think the other thing i would say is
that
for all of us uh one of our great
opportunities
our great challenge is to get over
whether it's hesitancy or equity or
uh more confidence is the more people
see this happening among their friends
and their families
and co-workers the more likely they are
to sign up and say you know what
i'm willing to play and and the walk-up
stuff has made a big difference too
i was visiting um i was visiting one of
our
uh pop-up sites last week and uh and
they had about
50 or 60 appointment visits they had 700
walk-ups
and i think i think the walk-up stuff
can be a really big deal in terms of
making sure that
we create other opportunities for people
especially younger people i get three
kids in their 20s
um i'm well aware of um how they feel
about appointment scheduling
um i think in many ways as we move as we
move down the
the age quartiles here being able to
just make this available in a bunch of
different locations and recognizing and
understanding that everybody doesn't
work off a calendar and a schedule
is going to be a big part of getting
this done we've also been talking to our
primary care docs and our pediatricians
about how they're going to help in our
schools about how they're going to help
us with
the the folks under the age of 16 the 12
to 15 community and
and i think in many ways the the biggest
thing we as governors have tried to do
is pursue a variety of data-driven
approaches based on what we're hearing
from people on the ground and
recognizing and understanding that
the same approach isn't going to work in
every place and you got to be willing to
be flexible
and put a lot of different approaches
into the mix to get this done now let me
just close again by saying
how much we appreciate the chance uh
we've had to work with your
administration on this
and and we're going to work really hard
to make sure we get everybody who wants
a vaccine vaccinated by the fourth of
july
well thanks charlie thank you you're
doing a hell of a job
uh governor lujan grisham
what about new mexico how are you doing
out there no we
uh as uh my good friend and colleague
governor baker mentioned that
we were leading and now all of these
fantastic governors and so many more
are chasing us or eclipsing us and this
positive as you say mr president
approach to getting every american
vaccinated is
making a difference and we are uh
effective collaborators and with your
team
and uh jeff science and others it
provides the kind of ecosystem for us to
leverage
any number of best practices and as i'm
i can tell you that we're going to meet
your goal and exceed it
uh by uh shots of first shots 70
by july 4th and we've made a statement
that by july 1
we're going to hit all of our uh targets
but i want to tell you for a
multicultural
incredibly majority state
23 sovereign nations in new mexico mr
president
and they're going to have 70 or more of
their population with
two shots by july 4th and probably
earlier and we have some
sovereign nations that have a 95
two shots in arms fully vaccinated
population and it's been a very
effective partnership with sovereign
nations
uh indian health service so the federal
government and your covenant team
under your leadership and it's made a
remarkable difference
because they were being hit hard but i'm
going to focus on a couple of things
that we did
a bit differently that i think really
contributed
to our ability to make sure that we were
equity focused and equity driven
we had the first in the nation
registration system and while
i do agree it's registering for a 16 or
17 year old may not be optimum
i was actually pleasantly surprised
at the number of new mexicans who early
registered for a vaccine and that data
that allowed us to see
whether or not we were getting minority
populations whether we were getting to
rural and frontier areas in the state
whether
uh highly uh concentrations of extreme
poverty whether we were getting
to those areas which meant that we could
then drive vaccine
both access and delivery to those
populations and like every state we used
that system
to do now walk-ins and pop-ups and any
business can
get on our site or call us or
communicate with us in any number of
ways no wrong door and we'll come to you
we'll set up automatically a vaccine
site as you've heard at a church at a
business
at a grocery store at a library at a a
pediatrician's office anywhere
everywhere
in the state and we're also using uh
mobile clinics
the third thing that we are doing that
we believe will also continue to do that
equity focused investment
we set aside 25 percent of our vaccines
at the very
earliest to make sure that we always had
equity driven
vaccine access but new mexico has more
than
50 percent more than half of our
population mr president is on medicaid
so now we can use that medicaid data and
i can tell you both from an
equity standpoint and just an access
standpoint
i can tell every primary care physician
who in their patient population is yet
to be vaccinated
and push those vaccines into those
doctors offices
by utilizing medicaid information and
it's that same utilization data
that tells me who's on hospice who's
homebound
who's got a disability so that we can
continue
to make sure that we close the gap every
single day
in terms of the mexicans who are yet to
be vaccinated
and i also think that the equity numbers
can improve
by many of the incentives that you're
hearing about and i'm going to use
medicaid as another
tool for incentives you can in medicaid
have kind of a points reward system
for people to engage in improving their
health outcomes
so we maximize we give you more of those
points
so that you can buy sports equipment for
your family and kids
so that you can engage in fresh farmers
markets and
this is another way that we get these
really hard to reach populations
using medicaid as a huge
driver and our registry system so data
making sure that we're pushing vaccines
into the communities
and then into the arms of new mexicans
every single day
and it uh it is working and so uh
i'm very proud of those systems that
we've uh stood up
and we're using every single other thing
that the
other governors have talked about and uh
we're committed
mr president to all of us continuing
this collaboration
every time somebody has a good idea i
heard about
hunting and fishing licenses i'm on it
so every time somebody has a good idea
we're deploying it and we appreciate
your support
to do that well you've done an
incredible job
and i i know you know jill i'm jill's
husband
uh been out to navajo nation now on
three occasions
and um one of the things that i just uh
a
closing comment i'm i'm i'm trespassing
on your time i know
but um i'm of you
and i've been characterized as
a congenital optimist so maybe you can
discount what i'm about to say
but i think the experience we've had
with what has been one of the because of
all of your work
the uh maybe the the most
significant major logistical
undertaking that we've ever done short
of war here
getting all this out and done
continuing it done i think we're going
to find
the lessons you've all learned and we've
all learned
from this are going to apply to a whole
hell of a lot more of what we do in
terms of delivering health care
and i'm not talking about more
government span i'm talking about
be able to communicate and connect
people
with basic health care and there's new
science going on right now
about the mrna you know capacity
to be able to adjust to maybe even
dealing with cancer and other
diseases and i think that i i i think
that it's
going to be other other pandemics and
we've got a
and i'm dealing with other world leaders
about how we're going to deal with it
because you
can't can't build a wall high enough to
keep a virus out
but i'm of the i am optimistic i think
we're going to see
in the next three or four years the
ability
to provide access to
and uptake of
significant additional healthcare
initiatives
that are going to affect everything from
the basic scientific research
the companies like pfizer and others are
going to be doing with their
and mrna mrna
vaccines as well as applying it to
other diseases as well and some of them
are communicable diseases at any rate
i just want to thank you all you know uh
you've done you've been great partners
in this effort and uh
i hope we haven't been uh um an
impediment
we've uh um i've we've tried like hell
no i really mean it we've tried like
hell
to include and engage you all
as much as we possibly could and not get
in the way
i know occasionally uh you know when i i
got some criticism when i decided we
were going to uh
engage the uh the
public health clinics around the country
and get them involved and
not from you all but uh you know from
others and
uh but i i think you've done an
incredible work and uh it's why i think
i think we get a lot more done at the
state level
in terms of cooperation among
democrats and republicans and we do
federally and so
none of this could have worked without
your leadership i really mean i'm not
trying to be solicitous i'm being
completely honest so thank you thank you
thank you
i think you're responsible i know you're
responsible for saving
thousands of lives the idea we've lost
well over 550 000 lives
more than every war we've fought
combined in one year basically is
astounding
and imagine what it would be if we
didn't have you all doing what you did
so thank you thank you thank you and one
other thing you're going to be hearing
about
it wasn't supposed to be part of what
i'm talking about but
every country in the world is now
looking to us
to provide for their lack of capacity
to produce and or have vaccines
i'm not going to shortcut the united
states of america i promise you
we're going to have enough vaccine for
every single american
but we are going to be engaged in
working with other countries
because they're going to be a lot of
variants that are going to be coming
from other countries that
we're going to have to be aware of as
well but um and i may get back to all of
you for some ideas on
how i go about doing that but i think we
can produce a whole hell of a lot more
vaccines
that we can make available we're already
how many we got out
we've committed to 60 million doses well
we're not using the astrazeneca
vaccine and i've committed the
distribution of 60 million doses to two
other countries our neighboring
countries who are
desperately in need of vaccines but
there's just an awful lot i literally
have
virtually 40 percent
of the world leaders calling and asking
can we help them and we're going to try
but anyway i just want to thank you
again for what you've done you've been
wonderful and
i look forward to seeing you all in
person as soon as we get everybody
we get above that 70 thank you thank you
thank you thank you
appreciate it thank you mr president
thank you thank you sir
very good punch excellent